if you're like me you just finished
chapter 12 of the mandalorian and was
like
[Music]
this episode was full of new clues as to
what moff gideon is up to
including one major reveal that hints at
him becoming the supreme leader of the
first order there's even an extra clue
how boba fett fits into all this so
you'll want to stick around till the end
of the video but before we get into it
make sure to like and subscribe as i'll
be coming out with new star wars videos
every week
chapter 12 sees mando back on navarro
the planet where he was originally
tasked with retrieving the child way
back in season 1.
in fact that's the episode where we're
first introduced to dr pershing who
seems to be moff gideon's chief
scientist and who we get an extremely
revelatory hologram message from during
the lab scene
in chapter 12. mando grief karga and
cara doon who now appears to be martial
around these parts
decide to check on an abandoned imperial
base once occupied by moff gideon's men
what they find is something that could
change this show completely
and tie it into the main series working
their way deeper into the base they
stumble upon a lab
before mando and the team can take care
of these two technicians they say
two important lines of dialogue purge
the drives and destroy it whatever
they've been up to here is highly
secretive and
probably not ethical considering the
floating bodies in these giant vats but
what are these experiments anyway when
the group discovers a hologram message
from dr
pershing addressed to moff gideon we
learned that he's been conducting
experiments that have gone terribly
terribly wrong injecting the blood of
the child into subjects results in the
bodies of the recipients to reject it
possibly deforming them like what we see
in these fats here dr pershing calls
these catastrophic failures
according to him the bodies accept the
blood for about a fortnight or
14 days before things go wrong but more
experiments will be needed and for more
experiments he'll need more blood
specifically blood with a high m count
referring to midichlorians you may
remember qui-gon jinn lecturing young
anakin about these in episode 1.
they're basically microscopic cells
found in all living organisms which
allows one to harness the force
the higher ones midichlorian count the
more one is force sensitive
the child is this high m count
individual pershing is talking about
in chapter 3 pershing was able to
extract a small sample of his blood
before the mandalorian interrupted his
experiment and took back the child this
is why dr pershing and moff gideon are
so adamant about getting the child back
as pershing says he doubts they'll ever
find someone with as high a midichlorian
count as he
and that's likely why they want the
child alive so they can keep extracting
blood until the experiment is perfected
in chapter 10 we see a group of
mercenaries ambush mando and try to take
the child
if you listen closely one of the merc
says not to harm the child
basically confirming these guys are
operating at the behest of dr pershing
and moff gideon due to the catastrophic
results of the experiments
pershing suggests they put any further
tests on hold at least until they can
get more blood he mentions someone
called
the volunteer who he fears would face
the same fate should the experiments
continue
and yes it's volunteer singular not
volunteers
and since this message is addressed to
moff gideon himself this volunteer is
probably not him since
pershing likely wouldn't have worded it
this way it's possible this volunteer is
someone we haven't met yet but my guess
it's someone who doesn't have any force
powers
and this brings me to why moth gideon is
conducting these experiments in the
first place
his obsession with becoming force
sensitive we've already
seen how he wields a darksaber and being
an imperial he would have likely seen
the power of the sith if there was a way
for those who weren't genetically born
force sensitive to somehow become
force users imagine how much more
powerful he'd become
and this leads to a crazy theory that
moff gideon will later become
supreme leader snoke in this episode
while looking at those vats of mutated
beings
pay close attention to the music in the
background
now listen to snoke's theme from the
force awakens
they actually used his theme here not to
mention vats appear here
as well as on the planet exogal where we
see discarded snoke clones we know that
snoke becomes supreme leader of the
first order
so this would fall in line with how moff
gideon is one of the top ranking
officials in what is currently left of
the empire i could
see a world in which moff gideon
undergoes one of these experiments
gets deformed in the process but
ultimately gains force powers then going
on to be used by palpatine
who we see has created more clones of
him and there absolutely is a tie-in to
clones here considering both dr pershing
and the two lab technicians
have the kaminoen emblem on their
uniforms the kaminones you might
remember from attack of the clones who
run the facility where all those jango
fett clones are made this might also tie
into the big reveal at the end of
chapter 9.
remember that boba fett was a clone made
by the kaminoans and i can't help that
this is all just one big coincidence if
boba fett found out the kaminoans were
providing clones to be tested on in
brutal experiments he'd probably join up
with mando
and bringing them down i think this is
why they've been teasing him for so long
waiting until the plot catches up for
them to pair him with mando the final
clue we get this episode are what appear
to be
dark troopers these are advanced battle
droids some legions of which are said
could use the dark side of the force
i'm not necessarily sure how that works
but zazum kath a sith commander who
worked under general palpatine
was said to have led such a group in
fact zazem and palpatine once
unsuccessfully tried to recruit boba
fett so again
this seems all too crazy to be a
coincidence but i want to hear you guys
weigh in on the latest developments of
chapter 12.
what do you think moff gideon is up to
and how does all this fit together
leave your comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like
subscribe and share and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt
until next time remember i have spoken
you